actor chadwick boseman died overnight at
the age of 43.
boseman is best known for playing the
title character in the marvel
blockbuster black panther
according to a family statement bozeman
had been battling colon cancer for the
past
four years cbs news chief medical
correspondent dr john lapook is a
physician and gastroenterologist
um and john this uh was just stunning
to learn overnight
jeff good morning yes it's shocking news
so sad and you know african americans
have a higher incidence of colon cancer
and a higher mortality from it
when they get it they tend to get it at
a younger age and it tends to be more
aggressive
which is why some societies are saying
you know instead of starting screening
at 50 which is standard
for most societies the american college
of gastroenterology saying you know
if you're african-american start at 45
and the american cancer society is also
saying everybody should be
screened at 45 because for some reason
cancer
colon cancer is affecting people at a
younger age now run through some of the
symptoms
and signs what should people be looking
for doc
hi michelle well yeah first of all
change in stool so that could be
anything from a change in
in caliber it could be more narrow you
could certainly have bleeding
you could have constipation diarrhea you
could also have bloating abdominal
discomfort
the stool doesn't have to be red in
terms of bleeding it could be just black
or dark
unexplained weight loss or if you just
fatigued and you turn out to have iron
deficiency anemia you can have iron
deficiency anemia from losing blood
invisibly in your stool
and by the way i know a lot of people
have diarrhea constipation it doesn't
mean you have
colon cancer but if you have any of
these symptoms you feel something's just
not right
please check uh check it all out with
your health care professional
you do not want to die of embarrassment
i know people don't want to talk about
things like this
yeah now just quickly those
over-the-counter
tests would you recommend them
well there are lots of ways of screening
you know there are stool tests that you
can look for dna or blood
but the gold standard is to do a
colonoscopy and
not only are you diagnosing uh colon
cancer at an earlier stage but you can
actually find a polyp
because michelle most in most cases
colon cancer starts
with a very benign polyp and it sits in
there for 5 10 even 15 years
benign but it's growing and if at any
point in that
you do a colonoscopy you can not only
find it but you can take it out
and the person instead of getting colon
cancer doesn't get colon cancer so
i would advise this is a wake-up call
and a reminder even though it's a time
of covid and people aren't seeing their
health care professionals as much please
check in and see if you need to get
screened
all right dr john the pook thank you
very much and it's as easy as reminding
a relative or a friend saying listen
go in for this get this done it could
save your life